athletes can now make money off their
name image and likeness the world of
college sports is changing dramatically
and many of those university officials
were in las vegas for the annual
convention that just wrapped up and as
logan reaver tells us tonight one of the
big topics has to do with name image and
likeness
on friday it'll be a year since the name
image in likeness role was placed into
effect in college sports at first there
was a hesitancy from athletic directors
all over the country and those here at
nacta since that time dudes have signed
on from everything from luxury cars to
just getting a couple more chicken
tenders from their favorite spots and
now it's only getting even bigger
you know people are referring it to the
wild wild west but you know we think we
have a really good product former notre
dame quarterback brandon wimbush now
helps current players get deals done
with his app name mogul fourth rushing
touchdown to blow this one open provide
value for
you know the other 99 percent of
athletes who are not the trevor
lawrence's or the zion williamson's
of the world which is where nil plays in
when it comes to unlv
sure the bucks aren't in the millions
but it drastically can change the life
of a rebel according to on three dot com
their market value system has junior
quarterback harrison bailey worth 72
thousand dollars and three star commit
keyshawn hall with a market value of 36
000 without even playing a game yet
and it might even help mid-majors like
them to have a chance to win i think
what it does more than anything else is
it actually establishes more parity in
collegiate athletics because now
athletes are going to be able to make
money no matter where they're going to
put the nil in perspective right now
2023 quarterback jaden rashada just
signed for 9.5 million dollars to a
miami booster that is more than most nfl
quarterbacks including trevor lawrence
kyler murray and joe burra who was just
playing for a super bowl back in
february from mandalay bay logan river
live local now all right thank you very
much